and now the fully grown Animated Feature
Oscar here are the nominees for best
animated feature film How to Train Your
Dragon directed by Chris Sanders and the
end of walk the illusionist directed by
Sylvan Show many
Toy Story 3 directed by Lee Unkrich and
the Oscar goes to be pretty cool for was
Banksy though right no okay okay Toy
Story 3 Yonkers
this is the first Academy Award for Lee
Unkrich who is also nominated tonight in
the adapted screenplay category
oh boy I can't believe I'm actually
saying this but thank you to the Academy
I wouldn't be standing here if it
weren't for the vision of three
incredible guys John Lasseter Ed Catmull
and Steve Jobs the founders of Pixar
Animation Studios which by the way is
the most awesome place on the planet to
make movies to my producer Darla
Anderson screenwriter Michael Arndt my
cast and crew everyone at Disney and
Pixar every single person who had
absolutely anything to do with making
Toy Story 3 and getting it out into the
world I share this with you too my
grandmother who always insisted that
she'd see me up here someday - my
parents my wife Laura my kids Hannah
Alice and Max I love you all so much and
finally thank you to audiences all over
the world who came out in historic
numbers and embraced a movie about
talking toys that hopefully had
something very human to say thank you
thank you thank you
you